so Dan was supposed to make an episode
this week but he was too busy playing
Skyrim to make an episode and so I was
gonna make one instead but I was too
busy playing Skyrim - so sharpen your
sword and grab your shield and let's
take a look at Skyrim so I'm not usually
big on calling spoiler warning in my
episodes because well I'm kind of a
prick
but I am gonna call spoiler warning here
because the game is fairly new so
warning there will be spoilers big
spoilers because we're going to be
looking at the main quest now the reason
for that even though this is a fairly
open-ended game the main quest defines
the central conflict for the game world
and even if you as a player would rather
be off mining or in Markarth the main
quest should still provide a solid
narrative arc with your character as
protagonist in Skyrim you play a
condemned criminal facing the execution
block the nature of your crime is poorly
defined and you might be innocent but
the Empire isn't too picky about due
process luckily a dragon shows up and
torches the place before they give you a
neck up hair cut
as you escape you team up with either
the lovably racist rebels or the lovely
totalitarian empire this scenario is
inherently hilarious because it means
running to safety with the guy who gave
you a death sentence for loitering
everyone's freaking out about the dragon
because in theory dragons don't exist
they're all supposed to be extinct or
imaginary but imaginary friends don't
burn down villages all in all you escape
the village and run away to the nearby
town of Riverwood where you learn more
about the lovable racists and/or the
lovable totalitarians since the dragon
attack is kind of big news on any day of
the week your new friends send you off
to the regional seat of government white
run which is run by whites the Big
Pimpin Ural balgruuf tells you to run
the news by his court wizard who says
that he can help if you go recover an
artifact that may or may not exist this
is just an in-game setup to expose your
character to his destiny which is sort
of like being exposed to cesium 137
probably fatal but it's a fictional
world so instead you get superpowers or
in this case you get a word of power
that you can't use because they want to
set the actual reveal up in a different
way than just using a funky glowing wall
so you return with the rock just in time
for a dragon to attack the western
watchtower unlike the typical video game
the yarol actually rally some troops
instead of sending you to do the job
alone after you and your dirty ride and
crew killed the dragon you go all
Highlander and devouring soul
mechanically this gives you the currency
you need to buy the ability to use the
word you learned off the wall from the
dungeon with the rock in story is to
explain that you must be dovakin or
dragon born because you have the natural
ability to drain power from dragons and
learn to use their words of power and
the Greybeards have summoned you up to
high Hrothgar at the top of the throat
of the world to check you over and see
if you're the real deal the Greybeards
are a sect of pacifist monks who
dedicate their lives to learning Turkic
words of power in order to become one
with creation most of this is explained
in bits and pieces by a bunch of
different NPC's over the course of a
couple hours of gameplay and actually
this is a good time for an interlude to
talk about pacing a lot of modern games
try to emulate other narrative formats
namely movies in terms of the flow of
information and how much time there is
between plot points games are inherently
slower paced than film because even if
what you're doing is advancing the plot
you tip
we have to do things in real time games
can't compress time without taking
control away from the player so if they
want you to climb a mountain then they
either take control away and do it in a
cutscene or you have to climb a mountain
incidentally Skyrim wants you to climb a
mountain when you finally get up to high
Hrothgar the monks run you through a few
tests to see if you're the real deal and
then after you demonstrate your
savant-like ability to master ancient
arcane techniques in seconds as only the
dovahkiin can they send you off to pick
up some old trinket from a tomb because
I don't know I guess the prophecy says
the dovakin has working legs
I guess climbing a mountain wasn't proof
enough whatevs the pacifist wants you to
go kill peeps that's cool when you get
the horn instead you find a note saying
that you're too late meet me at the
river wood in this just further goes to
prove the Greybeards were probably
hoping you just die and stay out of
their hair since someone else was able
to recover the horn anyway and they are
at the dovakin it's cool though since
the thief turns out to be Delphine a hot
warrior lady conspiracy nut she even has
a panic room built into her in she's got
a theory that the Dragons aren't just
returning they're being resurrected and
she wants you to prove that you're the
dovahkiin by murdering a dragon after it
gets up from the grave sho enough the
dragons being resurrected by the first
dragon from the beginning of the game
that dragon named Aldean taunts you for
a bit man flies off to do some more evil
and you kill the other dragon before he
even got to see sunrise again back at
Delphine's crash shacks she's convinced
that the thaw Lemar behind the dragon
invasion because they're trying to take
over the world and want the Empire to be
too weak trying to split attention
between dragons and the rebels to defend
against an invasion to confirm this she
asked you to sneak into a party at the
foreign embassy in the capital and snoop
around a bit she gets you a ticket to
the party and hooks you up with a mole
who will sneak your stuff in he tells
you to bring only the absolute
essentials for a stealth mission so of
course I packed my robot armor sword
shield a dozen potion Scrolls of mass
paralysis Scrolls of hysteria backup
weapons lock picks and proceeded to
murder every last elf I ran into and
stripped the place clean of valuables
all that you find out that the Thalmor
have no idea what's going on but they
name drop an old friend of Delphine's
from back in Nam fetch him from his
rathole
he leads you to sky to Haven temple
we're all doings walls fills out the big
story Halloween was an ancient badass
who ruled the world with an iron fist
some humans were taught the language of
the Dragons and use it to craft a word
of power to kill dragons called dragon
rend they defeated alduin but the
prophecy said he'd come back someday to
end the world unless the dovakin stops
him that starts a long segment where you
get sent to a lot of different places to
find bits and pieces to assemble this
super weapon of a word graybeard send
you to the top of the mound to speak to
a dragon who sends it to the mages guild
who sends you to their library and who
sends you to their insane colleague who
sends you to an ancient ruins who sends
you back in time yada yada yada the
overall plot doesn't really advance all
that much during this time but there is
a really interesting segment where you
talk with Paarthurnax the dragon at the
top of the mountain and he gives you
some long lectures about the nature of
words and how knowing words and their
meanings changes you he also suggests
some interesting philosophy at the end
of the world and implies that the job of
Dovahkiin and Anduin is to end the world
with their conflicts so that the next
world can sprout from the remains
unfortunately this element doesn't pay
off mechanically in the game since
there's never a big button you can push
that says start the apocalypse in fact
the rest plays out really
straightforward you confront and win on
top of the mountain kick his ass he runs
away you capture his friend and
convinced him to portray and when he
flies you to end one secret hideout
where you run through a portal to the
afterlife recruit the ancient heroes
that invented dragon wren kick and
wounds ask for good return to the land
of the living where some dragons stare
you down then fly off and that's it just
you and the wind on top of a mountain
and that's when I realized how badly I'd
screwed up
Skyrim doesn't have a narrative arc
because real life doesn't have a
narrative arc there's stories and mini
arcs but there's no final victory lap
there's where you start and where you
end and everything else in between
you killed Anduin awesome but the world
is still a messed up place the rest of
the Dragons aren't going to lay down
arms just because you killed their boss
and the whole province is still on the
brink of Civil War
everyone else had their things to get
done and since the world didn't end most
people won't even notice that you saved
it ultimately it's not about narrative
arc because the main quest is just a
running
a goal in a long checklist that
introduces you to new threads new people
in new places
the civil war the mages guild the
Thieves Guild the danger princes the
Dark Brotherhood the forsworn uprising
werewolves vampires brigands dragon
shrines and a million other errands and
tasks in the end Skyrim managed to tell
the kind of story that literature film
never can one that doesn't end also you
get to slam a dragon in the face